♪ STEVE ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME BACK.
A BIPARTISAN GROUP OF TEXAS
LAWMAKERS BACKING A NEW BILL TO
HELP RANCHERS LIVING ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH MEXICO
RECOVER FROM PROPERTY DAMAGE AND
VANDALISM CAUSED BY ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS.
THE ACT WOULD RE-PURPOSE
$300 MILLION FROM THE COVID
FUNDS TO HELP COVER CROP AND
LIVESTOCK LOSS.
FENCE REPLACEMENTS AND SO MUCH
MORE.
OUR NEXT GUEST IS NO STRANGER TO
THESE PROBLEMS.
HE ESTIMATES HE HAS SUSTAINED
$60,000 WORTH OF DANIEL ON HIS
LAND ALONE.
TEXAS RANCHER AND KITTY COUNTY
ATTORNEY BRENT SMITH JOINS US
FROM TEXAS.
GOOD MORNING, BRENT.
>> GOOD MORNING.
HOW ARE Y’ALL COOKING.
STEVE: TELL US ABOUT THE $60,000
OF DAMAGE YOU HAVE SEEN.
>> WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF PROPERTY
DAMAGE, OUR COUNTY IS BASICALLY
AT THE EPICENTER OF AN INVASION
IN MY VIEW.
YOU KNOW, THE LOSS OF FENCES,
THE EXTRA PERSONNEL COSTS.
THERE IS EVEN RANCHERS IN OUR
AREA HAVING TO HIRE PRIVATE
SECURITY OWN PROPERTY RIGHTS IN
AMERICA.
STEVE: THAT’S CRAZY.
>> US AMERICANS IN THIS PART OF
TEXAS WE DON’T HAVE THE SAME
RIGHTS AS OTHER PEOPLE DO.
WE CAN’T ENJOY OUR PROPERTY.
AND GO IN OUR BACKYARDS ANYMORE
AT NIGHT.
IT’S A TRAGEDY.
STEVE: IN ADDITION TO A
LANDOWNER, BRENT.
YOU ARE ALSO THE COUNTY ATTORNEY
THERE.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO REAL
RECOURSE, LANDOWNERS HAVE TO GET
ANY SORT OF REMUNERATION BACK
FROM ANYBODY, INSURANCE
COMPANIES, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, WHICH IS ALLOWING
THISALLOWINGTHISALLOWINGTHIS MIR
NOBODY?
>> IT’S A STOLEN VEHICLE GO
THROUGH THE PROPERTY THEIR
VEHICLE INSURANCE WON’T PAY FOR
IT AND OURS WON’T EITHER.
JUST ON MY PROPERTY ALONE WE
HAVE HERE OVER $60,000 THAT WE
HAVE END SP.
I KNOW THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHERS
ON A DAILY BASIS THAT HAVE TO
PAY EXPENSES.
NOT JUST THAT BUT THE LIVESTOCK
GET DOWNTOWN ROAD.
A VEHICLE HITS THAT COW, A
RANCHER IS GOING TO BE LIABLE.
SO DAMAGE COVERED UNDER THE
RAPID ACT IS LIVESTOCK LOSS,
CROP LOSS AND DAMAGE.
PERIMETER FENCE REPLACEMENT.
DAMAGES TO PHYSICAL STRUCTURES
AND PROPERTY LOSS.
YOU KNOW, IT JUST SEEMS, BRENT,
IF THE ADMINISTRATION IS GOING
TO SAY OKAY, WE’RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND LET THESE PEOPLE COME
ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER THAT
THEY WOULD ALSO COME UP WITH
SOME CASH DIRECTLY TO HELP YOU
FOLKS OUT.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE SAYING, DO YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THERE IS EXTRA MONEY IN THE
COVID FUND.
JUST TAKE SOME OF THAT BECAUSE
THERE IS SO MUCH OF THAT.
>> YEAH.
WELL, RIGHT NOW, THEY’RE
BRINGING COVID, TOO.
OUR JAIL SYSTEM RIGHT NOW IN OUR
COUNTY IS BASICALLY LOCKED DOWN
BECAUSE THE JAILERS AND EVERYONE
IN IT HAS COVID FROM ALL THE
INMATES.
STEVE: THAT’S SOMETHING.
YOU WERE TALKING EARLIER ABOUT
ARE PERSONAL SAFETY AND SOME
PEOPLE HAVE HAD TO HIRE PEOPLE
TO HELP THEM OUT WITH PERSONAL
SECURITY.
WHEN YOU GO OUT ON YOUR
PROPERTY, WHICH IS RIGHT THERE
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER, DO YOU
FEEL SAFE AT NIGHT?
NOT AT ALL.
>> WE DON’T EVEN FEEL SAFE
DURING THE DAY.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE A GUN WITH
YOU, YOU ARE TAKING CHANCE.
AND IT’S SAD THAT THAT’S REALITY
WE LIVE IN TODAY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE THE LAWS.
[BROKEN AUDIO]
WE DON’T NEED NEW LAWS.
WE NEED A PRESIDENT WHO ACTUALLY
ENFORCES THE LAWS ON THE BOOK.
SAD DAY IN AMERICAN HISTORY WE
HAVE TO FORCE OUR PRESIDENT TO
ACT AND ENFORCE THE LAWS ON THE
PECULIARS.
STEVE: WHAT WE HAVE SEEN, HE HAS
NO INTENTION OF DOING THAT PART.
HIS POLICY.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE SECRETARY
OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
THE STRATEGY IS, WOULDING.
AND ACCORDING TO YOU, PART OF
THE STRATEGY IS DAMAGING TEXAS
LANDOWNER’S PROPERTY ALONG THE
WAY.
>> VERY TRUE.
>> WE HAVE TRUE.
AND NOT ONLY DANG TO US, AS
LANDOWNERS, THE MIGRANTS COMING
OVER, TOO.
YOU KNOW, IT’S DAMAGING THEM.
THEY ARE BEING LEFT OUT.
THE CARTELS ARE ABSOLUTE CONTROL
OF BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER
RIGHT NOW.
THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OF THE
BORDER.
THERE IS NO BORDER.
STEVE: WELL, IT’S A DIRE
SITUATION DOWN THERE.
AND WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
BRENT, FOR GETTING UP EARLY TO